zur vorweihnachtszeit präsentiert sich
die deutsche hauptstadt besonders
festlich überall glänzt und glitzert es
wie hier am brandenburger tor auf der
straße unter den linden und auf dem
kurfürstendamm eine shopping tour über
die weihnachtlich beleuchteten
boulevards gehört zum pflichtprogramm im
advent für besucher und auch die meisten
berliner
die erste adresse für weihnachtseinkäufe
ist in berlin das kaufhaus des westens
kurz kadewe das wohl bekannteste
warenhaus deutschlands mit 60.000
quadratmetern verkaufsfläche ist es
eines der größten in europa jedes jahr
verwandelt sich das foyer in ein
weihnachtswunderland das diesjährige
weihnachtszeit christmas journey eine
reise durch die großstädte der welt new
york und paris st petersburg und london
indem traditionskaufhaus finden die
besucher nicht nur geschenkideen sondern
auch die neuesten dekorations trends für
weihnachten
und mittendrin ein weihnachtsmann bis
heiligabend residierte hier kinder
können ihre weihnachtswünsche verraten
und er ist ein beliebtes motiv für
erinnerungsfotos
es kommen ja viele leute die kommt
deswegen eigentlich nur hier vorbei ist
bei dem weihnachtsmann hallo sagen
bei den vielen internationalen besuchern
hat der kdd weihnachtsmann mittlerweile
fans auf der ganzen welt
der besuch einer märchenaufführung
gehört in deutschland für viele familien
zur vorweihnachtszeit mitten in berlin
werden in zwei rustikalen holzhütten
märchen der brüder grimm aufgeführt
jeden tag gibt es bis zu fünf
verschiedene vorstellungen
vor zehn jahren hatten produzent
christian schulz und seine theatergruppe
die idee dazu
wir haben die märchen für kinder
konzipiert und ihre erwachsenen sie mit
den kindern linien und wir haben gemerkt
ihr später der abend desto mehr
erwachsene als kinder in den erwachsenen
im publikum mittlerweile haben wir viele
vorstellungen für kinder aber noch sehr
viel mehr für erwachsene und klar in der
vorweihnachtszeit da ist märchenzeit da
das haben wir nicht erfunden auf dem
spielplan stehen welt bekannte märchen
wie aschenputtel schneewittchen oder
hänsel und gretel die geschichte von den
geschwistern die von ihren eltern im
wald ausgesetzt werden und am haus einer
hexe landen
die mädchen werden von den schauspielern
frei interpretiert natürlich nimmt die
geschichte von hänsel und gretel ein
gutes ende
in der aufführung ganz wichtig das
publikum wird immer mit einbezogen
würde er meine kinder frage also mir das
aufgefallen
ebenfalls tradition in deutschland ein
besuch auf einem der weihnachtsmärkte in
berlin gibt es mehr als 60 verschiedene
als eine der schönsten gilt der
weihnachtszauber gendarmenmarkt jedes
jahr kommen rund 600.000 besucher aus
aller welt hierher
fast alle probieren eine original
thüringer rostbratwurst
sie wird nach einem mehr als 600 jahre
alten rezept hergestellt mit gewürzen
wie majoran und kümmel
eine weitere spezialität ist der
glühwein reiser rotwein mit nelken zimt
und anis mit seinem unverwechselbaren
duft ist über ein ein traditioneller
bestandteil der vorweihnachtszeit in
deutschland weihnachten dazu auf den
weihnachtsmarkt zu gehen sich zu freuen
dass die weihnachtszeit naht des jahres
vorüber und es genießen viele leute in
der kleinen runde mit einer leckeren
tasse glühwein für die
weihnachtsbeleuchtung am kurfürstendamm
ist berlin berühmt
noch bis anfang januar verwandelt sich
der boulevard jeden abend in ein
dreieinhalb kilometer langes nicht mehr